un petit peu j'en fais un petit peu à
jean paul belmondo l'amour c'est quoi
pour vous l'amu tactique c'est moi mais
l'amour [ __ ] piano l'amour mais c'est
un double saut périlleux entre la
baignoire et lobby des rétablissements
sur la moquette
je vois une belle si je me précipite sur
elle je lui fais l'amour
elle me dit c'est bon c'est bon je sais
juste le mari rentré me surprend je me
faufile nu dans la penderie
imaginez la scène il me dit que faites
vous là je lui dis je chasse les mythes
il me dit dans cette tenue au monde du
helmand d'où boucher
à sa merci du cadeau parce que ils
paraissent diva et merci mon dieu s'il
savait que le père spirituel de jean
paul s'était gabin harris ça oui c'est
vrai show ce gamin je posais eu le temps
de manger bon la gueule et puis je me
pose des questions à la con tu gauche a
bombardé l'île était plaisant combien il
était génial puisse être la fille mars
pour la porter de fait l'amitié d'être à
la vie elle tendra peut-être un jour un
film avec coluche peut être c'est que je
sais quand même comment celui-ci
prendrait pour la convaincre de tourner
avec lui je sais pas je sais pas
conneries non ça dépend si elle aime et
vous aimez prince charmant des princes
charmants parce que j'ai une histoire je
sais pas si qu'elle arrive et je peux
passer la muraille c'est une charte sera
princesse ses gonzesses comme ça sur le
bord de l'eau petit voyou qui se noie
alors elle aime bien les loups la
gonzesse à l'arrêt sauve le louper c'est
à vous comme brigitte bardot deviens pro
et la trappe le loup bon à la table ou
par l'accueil in extremis à le sort par
là tu attrapes rappelé que sans pareils
que et le loup il se transforme en
prince charmant et il dit maintenant
vous pourrez me lâcher
souvent d'ailleurs
mais ceux de france culture bonsoir
c'est une histoire extrêmement délicate
ce qui je ne savais pas mais je
m'attends au pire maintenant maintenant
recevoir la gaze bourg de bosser dur
alors gainsbourg il manquait ce qui me
manque un petit peu trop habillée moi je
trouve 6 ha oui cigarettes d'abord à
tanguer ce bourg il faut la cigarette je
me suis rasé je suis désolé ces deux
hommes
je sais pas comment je serai pour la
draguer mais je pense que c'était plus
mais j'ai serré les cernes et continue
on dirait vraiment ici faire étiage je
mènerai suis vraiment les étraves
j'aime bien tiens prendre à ma poste
ressentir sur mon alors phoenix est le
magazine d
tremblay qui lui ressemble sûrement
faire à temps faut être un petit peu
plus et petit roupillon après
et
qu'il a fait mieux que lui c'est le fun
bon alors maintenant je voulais dire à
sophie jullien rockeur ouais mais tu
sais qu'un jour je suis un rocker il
n'est pas chez vous avec la banane je
sais qu'un jour j'ai pris la balade avec
jacky on a présenté veille lançant ma
mère n'a pas encore pardonné alors
maintenant ouais je voudrais dire que
sophie vous risque un jour de rencontrer
sur un plateau de cinéma
patrick sébastien caron parle de plus en
plus de l'acteur géants vivent
j'ai envie d'en craig dans l'eau je vois
ce carnaval ouais et que je valais pas
si je pouvais avec les charlots je
mesure la distance qui vous sépare
décidément de plus en plus réduit un
vieux producteurs c'est très dur ma vie
s'est réduit de 2,3 mois alors
maintenant on va retrouver le patrick
sébastien j'avais avec un hommage qui
reste sa ses anciens mais ça reste dans
le tour de l'ain bien j'ai changé mon
gégé et demi les personnages nouveaux
donc dont tu as parlé tu fumes pote tu
demandes un petit peu mais je me démerde
animaux ouais bon alors tu veux un jeux
d'hier jeudi on n'a pas eu un personnage
nouveau tu vois et de ciboure villerest
de quitter ce qui m'a dit sapritch nom
de sébastien laprise sa tronche yade à
l'échantillon à la dent alors de finesse
et maureen je ne supporte pas qu'on dise
du mal comme ça alors pourquoi vous
comprendrez alors deux fines et
cibouriens quelqu'un qui a mangé du
crunch à côté d'elle mais c'est tout bon
alors de funès de funés ces vauriens
vous les avez gardé d'abord parce que
parce qu'ils font partie du paysage on
parce que je les adore parce qu'ils font
partie des gens que les les
les personnages que les gens aiment le
plus et place des mre ont retrouvé mort
à tanger m mes chaussettes dans mes
pantalons thillois
voilà et puis j'ai fait un petit mélange
de deux sketches que j'avais fait avec
bourvil et de funès vers le temps de
mettre mon béret puis je vais vous faire
la rencontre pour villé et dessus et
voilà ce qui nous permet d'applaudir
sophie marceau qui va nous quitter bercy
cette liste
et les yeux qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
je veux c'est sécuritaire que me
recevoir
ce soir j'avais gauzy aussi c'est que le
désert qui arrive quand il m aurait
peut-être pousser des dromadaires sur
les cordes vocales
alors je suis venue pour nous et et
l'oms mais qui jouait là-bas j'avais pas
vu depuis la grande vadrouille mu
devrions louis tu me reconnais pas
séparé utilities possibilities it is it
is it is easy by titi lui et yves haïti
c'est giscard c'est giscard est aussi le
jour y est passé devant l'elysée il
faisait maison est bon ma biche ma biche
mind klein bic est une
vous aviez des regards des lilas il a
pas changé il est toujours aussi abrutir
vous en êtes pas changé non plus est
toujours aussi ras du sol c'est pareil
tener farouk et vous vous êtes faut pas
aller vous promener dans leur savuth
atelier sur les voies et il faut
s'accepter comme on est mon vieux moi je
m'accepte bien comme on est à beaubourg
bouge
vous êtes petit il faut pas vous énervez
pas alors je suis petit je suis à
yamgname petit j'étais plus ça ne
m'énerve pas du tout quoi je suis très
petit je suis tout petit je m' arrive là
les yeux sont là je n'ai hélas vers
l'avenir
je suis tout petit je suis un bonjour
monsieur bouvard regardez-vous variés là
où il est grand il était voilà c'est ça
dites moi ma biche et parce que drucker
que je sais dites moi ma biche
qu'est-ce que vous devenez vous avez
vous le savez maintenant je m'occupe des
tiges en commun sinon bah non qu'elle
veut jouer joue un petit pas comme ça un
petit peu parce que je voulais en avoir
un petit alors j'ai fait venir un du
bout du monde que j'ai adopté comme ça
comment envoyer par avion cha un
étranger genouilly pour sipam à calmer
ou gt3 et là j'ai pas n'importe quoi au
nom
d'ailleurs si la lumière se baissent un
peu je vais vous raconter tiens je vais
vous raconter quand je suis allé
chercher à l'aéroport
comment ça s'est passé c'était c'était
un enfant siens un enfant de poubelles
en petit presque rien un mauvais coup du
ciel il était né là bas loin dans des
pays vieux fera presque à deux pas pour
un coeur de ce lieu
- je me suis battu pour avoir ce
mendiant
j'ai signé des papiers pour qu'ils
portent mon nom le voilà qui arrive tout
tordu tout tremblant c'est un enfant qui
naît du ventre d'un avion les vitraux
d'orly ce sont fait brouillard je pleure
pour un petit que je ne connais pas qu
importe sa couleur qu'importe son
histoire m'a
moi je m'habitue rey à son prénom
bizarre dans quelques mètres à peine il
sera dans mes bras
le pas lui dire je t'aime et et
comprendraient pas simplement lui
sourire le prendre par la main juste lui
demander tu n'as pas un peu faim il est
blottie là contre mon épaule et
maintenant le caresser son coeur
cabriole il renverse cette aide pour me
regarder mieux dans ses yeux c'est la
fête
je sais qu'il est heureux il y a des
enfants un chien lance monde poubelles
des petits presque rien des mauvais
coups du ciel qu'ils attendent que toi
qui n'attendent que nous pour embrasser
nos vies et puisse prendre à nos coûts
allait bien